so now that we understand what address
addresses are let's look at how the fund
transfers actually happen in bitcoin and
what i'm going to describe is what's
called uh one particular payment
mechanism in bitcoin called pay to
public ehash and the way this works is
um by issuing transactions so what is a
transaction well a transaction has a
number of inputs we'll see the format of
inputs in just a minute
and then it has a number of outputs okay
so here in this case we have two
transaction outputs we call these
outputs when they're first created we
call them utxos utxo stands for unspent
transaction outputs okay and that's
actually where funds are going to be
held
so what the transaction says is how many
bitcoins are going to be transferred to
this address
and how many bitcoins are going to be
transferred to that address so you can
see the address itself is the hash of
the public key the address here is the
hash of a different public key so hfpk1
is going to get one one value h of bk2
is going to get another value and that's
going to be
recorded on the blockchain so everybody
knows that this amount of funding was
transferred into these two addresses
now later on
maybe years later
there might be another transaction
issued so far we've only looked at one
transaction years later there might be
another transaction issued that
basically
by the way i should say transaction
number one is going to be recorded on
the blockchain and can never be removed
now once transaction two issues well
here we have let's see we have one
transaction input and again we have two
transaction outputs so we already know
what the transaction output structure
here is right so we have a value and we
have an address
the input structure is the following so
the first component of a transaction
input points to a previously unspent
utxo so in this case basically what this
says is that the input to this
transaction is basically the value that
was associated with this utxo
and then there's a signature that
basically says i authorized the value in
the utxo to be spent as an input to this
transaction okay so the owner of this
address again authorizes this uh
spending of this utxo
and then once the authorization happens
basically the value is provided as input
to the transaction and then is
distributed to the output addresses
as specified in the output of the
transaction so
just to be clear the person who creates
transaction number two is actually the
person who wants to spend funds okay so
the owner of this utxo is the one who
creates the transaction
and what he's actually saying is i want
to take the funds in in the utxo that i
had and i want to distribute those funds
to these two addresses uh in the amount
specified in the uh in the outputs okay
and then to authorize expenditure he
provides a signature and that signature
tells the world yes i'm really
authorizing that those funds be
distributed okay so the values that are
specified everywhere is basically
amounts to be paid in bitcoin and again
it's important to understand these
amounts can be fractional so you don't
have to pay
a whole bitcoins you can pay
0.001 bitcoin if you wanted to as we saw
that before
and that's that's basically how funds
are being transferred so what's
important to understand
is that value in the bitcoin blockchain
is held in these utxos yeah once a utxo
is spent it can never be spent again
essentially the value disappears from
the utxo and you can never ever spend
that utxo it becomes a spent transaction
output and it's basically forgotten
okay so if you wanted to say transfer
money from one address that you own to
another address that you own yeah you
would basically issue a transaction say
that transfers it from one utxo to
another utxo it just hap so happens that
you own those both of those addresses
owning an address means you have the
secret key that allows you to sign on
behalf of that address
so again if we look at the example
transaction we saw in the previous
segment you can see there are two input
addresses here there are two output
addresses
you can see the amounts that were
transferred right to each one of those
addresses
these are basically pointing to utxos
that contain the amounts in the total
inputs and again once those utxos are
spent there can they can never be used
again the addresses can be spent can be
used as many times as we want but the
utxos the unspent transaction outputs
can never be used again okay so that's
the idea behind uh the utxo model that's
used in the bitcoin blockchain it's
actually quite clever
makes it makes it so that miners don't
have to keep the entire blockchain in
memory all they have to do is just keep
the set of utxos in memory and they can
make sure that a utxo is never spent
more than once and all the value in the
blockchain network is held in these
utxos and again the owner of a
particular address
is the person who has the secret key
that allows him to sign on behalf of
that address